yeah it's a very exciting day and uh
we're surrounded by activity uh if if
it's if it's not military bans it's
people cleaning the streets but it's all
happening here as we get ready
yeah now uh lots of important rules for
all sorts of people particularly the
Archbishop of
um artificial of York you of course um
will be having challenges as well for
people like the bishop of Durham I've
been reading about him he and his
colleague have to make sure that the
king doesn't trip up today
yes I think we've had lots of rehearsals
uh well every day this week but also for
the last couple of weeks and it's it
it's a beautiful very Grand but quite a
complicated service getting the
choreography rights and and the right
things handed in in the right order in
the right place uh has taken some
practice
um and uh and yes I think the the king
um you know he he's concerned that he's
not going to trip over the robes while
he's holding orbs and sectors so we've
had a lot of smiles as we've worked out
what to do but but I know it's going to
be a very very beautiful
um a very moving and and I hope a very
meaningful service for all of us
um whether we're taking part as I have
the honor to do or whether you're
watching at home
yeah um what is going to be I'm gonna
guess you're gonna say the anointing but
I'm going to ask you anyway the most in
the most important part for you as a man
of the cloth
yeah well I I think for me the most
important part actually is the very
opening Words which is one of the new
things in what is obviously a very
historic service but the very first
thing the king says first of all he's
addressed by a child and the first thing
he says is uh what words of Jesus I come
not to be served but to serve and I
believe that's very important for King
Charles it's a note that struck
throughout the service that that
leadership is about service that's what
we want in our leaders and I believe
that's what that his mother the Queen
and King Charles I think that's how they
see monarchy so actually that opening
sentence is probably for me the most
moving of all though there's lots of
other wonderful things to follow
Archbishop I wonder if you have a view
on the homage of the people there was a
little bit of controversy over that when
the Archbishop of Canterbury talked
about it
um suggestions that the British public
and the others should say I swear that I
will pay true allegiance to your majesty
and to your heirs and successes
according to law so help me God do you
think it's a good idea
well of course in British public life
many of us myself as as uh as a a
minister in the Church of England and as
a member of the House of Lords people in
the armed forces it's quite a normal
thing for many of us to to swear an oath
of Allegiance which is about
um our belonging to one another within
our nation which which obviously the the
king is our head of state so on the one
hand it's a very ordinary thing to do I
think it was a good idea to open the the
auto to extend an invitation for
everybody to do that if they wished
um but but I think the point I'd simply
want to make is let's not get too hung
up on this it's an invitation and I know
there are many people who for instance
when the national anthem comes on the
Telly they stand up and sing and I so I
think for for many people they will be
glad to join in in some way from their
sitting rooms
um but nobody has to
yeah just before I let you go you're
closer to God than I I'm sure that
you've had a word with upstairs is it
going to rain
well I think it is going to rain
um but uh rain is a sign of blessing in
fact um I was chatting with with the
King yesterday about this and we both
agreed that obviously we'd prefer it if
it was a sunny day but we're going to
take we're going to take the rain as a
sign of blessing I mean I feel sorry
with the rain I feel sorry for the
thousands of people who who are lining
the streets it's going to be hard for
them but there we are we can't do
anything about that but what we can do
is enjoy the day
first good name drop of the day and what
a one it was when I was speaking to the
king just yesterday thank you very much
indeed for joining us enjoy the service
thank you